a big moment last night Kim Cattrall
shows up to the Emily in Paris season
three premiere there are a lot of
theories people think that that might be
Darren's wink wink to the world that she
could be joining the cast for season
fourth she could be Sylvie's Nemesis
Emily's Mom Antoine's mistress what do
you make of this do you know anything
amazing mom Mindy's mom who knows yeah I
mean I'm just bummed that I didn't get
to say hi to her last night I know you
didn't even realize that I didn't get to
see it I did I spoke to she was so kind
and so sweet about the show and I had no
idea that she was going to be there so I
I literally was like I wow thank you for
showing up
um no we I think she just wanted to be
there and it was so kind and yeah we
don't know if I've heard the rumors too
I don't know that would be really fun we
have to find you know because Kim
joining the cast of anything he's
amazing is amazing and you know with
yeah you're nodding your head you're
like yes
the right opportunity and you know but
it was really so wonderful for her to
come and and support all of us um she
lives in London part of the year so I'm
like him you're just like just take the
train and come over and she did you said
that you'd love for Kim Cattrall to come
in and play Antoine's mistress and last
night who shows up at the Emily in Paris
Premiere Kim Cattrall this is what is
called manifestation
I put it out there last night she came
and I said hi remember me Prada guy 35
seconds and in the insects she was so
lovely I I and she was you know she was
with us last night obviously and uh I
got my picture with her and I would I
mean that would be uh you know it's in
the back of my mind we talked about a
few things where I sat with her for a
little bit we talked about our life in
New York and all that but I was so
tempted to make that leap and and say
about
I think I think things you know will
happen if they have to happen it'll
happen organically but I think it would
be it sounds like the perfect uh
scenario you know For an upcoming season
whether it's five or six fingers crossed
I don't know anything about it I think
that's the best kept secret yeah wow
what do you make of that would you be
excited with that it's amazing she's
incredible I mean she's a Nike yeah
iconic but you haven't pitched anything
there's not like a specific role have
you talked to her about this nothing
specific nothing specific don't give
them anything but you know the door's
always open for him is there a role that
you you think God she would just crush
it in that in that spot just a new I
mean every time they add a new role
we're like oh my gosh that's such an
interesting spin on something or that's
it yeah so I think just an icon in some
way yeah coming in or herself like
honestly that wouldn't be that weird
because my characters definitely grew up
with watching Sex in the City 100 she
had posters on her wall yeah exactly
what we needed three single gals back on
the town That's So Meta because a lot of
people think some Samantha Jones the
character she's in London doing PR this
is a show about marketing I've heard
that Samantha Jones could exist in this
Darren star universe and Alfie goes back
to London that's that's mad averse let's
go to London guys so many ideas yeah
[Music]